tough act to follow Mack and I have at
least one thing in common both of us
reached our peak physical condition in
the same way by going vegan more
athletes are ever before speaking out
for animal rights and whether it's
veganism taking on the fur industry or
fighting animal overpopulation the
collective voice of the sports world has
never been stronger we're here tonight
to show you some of the remarkable
athletes who have stepped up to the
plate from the college level to
professional sports from Olympians to
the biggest stars in the NFL and NBA
cyclists figure skaters tennis players
triathletes and fighters we're proud to
present Peter's all-stars